افاد مراسل الجزيره باصابه فلسطيني بجروح
خطيره وتعرضي اخرين لحالات اختناق اضافه
الى اعتقال ثلاثه في بلده قباطيه جنوب
جنين شماليه ضفه الغربيه وافدى مراسل
الجزيره بان عشرات الاليات العسكريه توغلت
في بلده قباطيه وحاصرت عددا من المنازل
قبل ان تقتحمها وتعبث بمحتوياتها واضاف
المراسل وان مواجهات مع الفلسطينيين دلعت
في بعض المناطق مع قوات الاحتلال التي
اعتدت عليهم واطلقت قنابل الغاز والاعيره
المطاطيه والذخيره الحيه تجاههم قبل
انسحابها
كما افاد مراسل الجزيره باصابه فلسطينيين
بجروح خطيره في مخيم الدهيشه جنوب مدينتي
بيت لحم صباح اليوم جراء اطلاق جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي النار على فلسطينيين
محتجين على اقتحامهم للمخيم
وفدا شهود عيان بان قوه عسكريه من الجيش
الاحتلال اقتحمت المخيم وهو ما اداه الى
اندلاع مواجهه
كانت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد قتلت
امسي فلسطينيا اعزل قرب بلده سلواد شرقيه
مدينه رام الله وذلك من المسافه السفر بعد
الاعتداء عليه بالضرب واظهر فيديو لحظه
اطلاق النار على الشهيد احمد كحله وقالت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان احمد كحله
استشهد بعد اصابته برصاصه في عنقه وقد
تراجع الجيش الاحتلال عن روايته بشان
محاولته كحله عمليه طعن دون اعطاء مزيد من
التفاصيل
لمتابعته الاوضاع في مختلف الاماكن في ضفت
هي الغربيه
من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد رام
الله مرحبا وليد همم همم وليد العمري عفوا
مرحبا بك وليد تفاصيل هذا التوتر المطرب
حتى الان هناك 16 حاله اعتقال في انحاء
مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال خلال الليله الماضيه وصباحها هذا
اليوم لكنها تركزت بشكل خاص في بلده
قباطيه في جنوب جنوب مدينه جنين في شمال
الضفه الغربيه وكذلك مخيم الدهيشه الجنوبي
بيت لحم وبلده حسام غربي بيت لحم خلال ذلك
كان هناك اصابتان خطيرتان احداهما في
قباطيها
في الراس والاخرى في مخيم الدهيشه لطفل في
الرابع عشر من عمره وبالاضافه هذه العديد
من حالات الاغماء المعلومات التي وصلت من
شهود العيان في كافه الاجزاء ان قوات
كبيره من جيش الاحتلال كانت قد دهمت هذه
المناطق واقتحمتها وان مواجهات دارت في
العديد منها وخلال تلك المواجهات استخدمت
قوات الاحتلال الذخيره الحيه وايضا قنابل
الغاز
قامت بعمليات مداهمه واقتحام للعديد من
المنازل التي حصلتها في قباطيها المعلومات
انها الحمله تركزت على اسرى محررين ينتمون
للجهاد الاسلامي بشكل خاص ثلاثه منهم تم
اعتقالهم كذلك الوضع في الاماكن
الاعتقالات الاخرى واضح بان القوات
الاحتلال تواصل عمليتها الواسعه التصعيديه
في كافه ارجاء الضفه الغربيه وكما قلت في
البدايه 16 معتقلا حتى الساعه هم ما تم
رصدها عمليات الاعتقال في انحاء في
الانحاء المختلفه وفي مخيم الدهيشه ايضا
كان هناك اشتباكات وكان هناك مداهمات وتمت
عمليات الاعتقال كذلك كانت بلده حسام قد
سائده ومناطق اخرى كثيره في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال في عمليتها التصعيديه واضح
بانها تصل
وتستهدف كافه الفلسطينيين واحادثه الامس
التي قتل فيها الشهيد
ابنه كانت دليل قاطع على ان الامور تتجه
نحو مزيدا من التصعيد اضف الى ذلك كله ان
القوات الاحتلال تهدد وتنذر بانها ستقوم
بعمليات هدم لمنازل من تتهمهم بتنفيذ
عمليات ضدها كما ان هناك اجواء تصعيديه
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه على وجه الخصوص
لتعيد العمل ضد منطقه الخان الاحمر
الشرقيه القدس بين القدس وبيت لحم وكذلك
منطقه مسافر يطا وهو ما يشير الى ان هذه
الحكومه وخلافا لما وعدت به الحكومات
السابقه للولايات المتحده وايضا
الاوروبيين يبدو انها ستعود للسياستها
القديمه وهي محاوله اخلاء هذه المناطق
والاستلاء عليها من جديد وهو ما يرى به
الفلسطينيون ان من شانه ان يضع حدا لانه
سيقطع ضفه الغربيه الى نصفين كاملين بمعنى
انه لن يكون هناك ت الجغرافي بين جنوب
الضفه وشمالها من هذه المنطقه اذا ما
اقدمت قوات الاحتلال على اخلاء خان الاحمر
لا سيما وان اعضاء كنيست من احزاب
الصهيونيه الدينيه المفرطه في تطرفها
كانوا قد وصلوا الى منطقه خان الاحمر امس
في ايطاليا عمليتهم للتحريض من جديد ضد
هذه المنطقه على كل حال حملات الاعتقال
تتواصل 16 هذه الليله والعدد الاجمالي منذ
بدايه العام ارتفع الى اكثر من 200 شكرا
جزيلا وليد العمري قدنا معنا من رام الله